there is a word that has a lot of
meetings it's like that's not fair or
let's go to the fair um what a really
really old-fashioned meanings for the
word fair is beautiful but attractive
all right so I get up to beauty because
I want all of your grass to be fair fair
grabs that look good what is fair stares
form okay let me help you
the first and the first letter other
adjectives factorize now I gave your
ground a gradient for after the first
place was already factoring in to stop a
driver do fibrosis why is that why is
very important okay everything gets
easier to find asymptotes intercepts are
all the regions tough enough to show you
I stretch it forth all the way easier to
find if you have a flatterer okay
Arthur factorize ACS for asymptotes now
please note there are different kinds of
acetones right dear fruit pies of
asymptotes so the first one which is
really easy to find other vertical
asymptotes wicked vertical asymptotes
comfortable you generally look at the
denominator right so whiskers
denominator is equal to zero when the
denominator is equal to zero you will
get a vertical asymptote so that's the
domain you can't ever cross that because
the nominee is company zero right this
is why you can't cross the vertical
asymptotes but you can't cross
horizontal answer terms horizontal
asymptotes point all we had at the
bottom y equals zero where you get there
for something to do the denominator up
in Italy vs. right so you think about
limits as X approaches positive and
negative infinity positive negative is
it okay now just a little quick note
which I will come back to later on
they're vertical
there's horizontal there's actually a
third time called an oblique asymptote
their assets words that are often a
funny angle they're very much like
horizontal apertures in there about
limits so I will get to those into time
they're a bit more complicated they're
sort of sort of outside the scope of the
course because never actually mentions
the word of the Gazan time but I will
show you later on once you've worked
some stuff with polynomials about how to
find them I think that was a sentence
you might have had against about what I
stands for think it deserves
so just remember flat asymptotes there
are two kinds or two inside the
description looking for a good way okay
luckily our stairs for what we did up
here in peak what was our engine regions
thank you certain regions are about the
sign of your grammar are you positive
I'm negative shade in the Accord area
and then you know where your autograph
has to go through so this is really
about
so is it plus or is it once these four
steps will get you through these
prospects will get you through so what I
want you to have a go at is using those
four steps on this graph here X minus
one x squared plus two X Factor eyes
search for your asymptotes evaluated
step if they're already shades of
regions and it off you go okay I'll let
you have a pivot to get done look at how
we did it yet how did I do the region
see what did I rely on IQ some lines
right I drew those orange lines that
correspond to the what are they contour
to X X is two x plus two
in other words the factors right if you
do the fact is that's why you have to
factor X then you control those orange
lines then off you go okay
what I've done is all the set up work I
factorize you can see it right here I
put in all my action shows there are
three how do I know what the vertical
asymptotes are I look at the denominator
in x equals zero the denominator will be
zero if X is negative 2 the denominator
will still be zero so that's where I get
these vertical asymptotes from I've got
a whole lot of 1 where did I come from
as a specificity you take the limit the
same thing is happening on both sides
in fact which is pretty much universal
things so I've got my wife cause you're
in the complete label in there make sure
you label yours my intercepts I don't
have any y-intercepts why is that
because I already determined one step
ago that you can't let X equal zero it's
in the denominator right to there you
can't get anyone steps you take an x
intercept though and you get that from
the numerator for the numerator is zero
right so by Latinos factorizing means
you look at the denominator we say r0g
are giving you acetones
you look at the numerator 0 TR gives you
intercepts and you can see I've got
lines right there at x equals 1 I then
shaded my regions just like in the
previous example I have 3 faster lines
which gives me this up/down pattern and
now comes the fun line now I have to
look at this and fit in the curve that
obeys all of these constraints that I've
set up okay you all see it is quite
frequently look at the bottom left-hand
side what shape you're going to get
you're going to get that thought ahead
cover the shape over here
sort of stuck at this corner so you go
ahead and you draw a car you what about
in here what's happening okay now even
though it does we're going round I'm not
going to say forever because and you
look out at the ball
it's got asymptotes it's got a domain
restriction which brothers do not see
not so therefore it sort of looks like
that but there you go there's a check
then you is last weird bit over here now
what's happening what's happening we
know a few things we know we've got to
get down to this asymptote in the corner
we also do we have to approach
you stood here and you notice I've drawn
it just with a gentle downward curve why
is that why do they have to be going
from that side there's an accent on your
notes approaching but how do I know it's
approaching from that side not from this
side because that's the region this is
why we do this right you shade the
region you said it has to be positive in
that area because look at my orange
lines 1 2 3 they're all positive there's
no way you can be coming from down here
so that means you've got to be coming
from up here but if you're up here
somewhere and you've got to get back
down here that means you have to at some
point turn around ok so therefore I know
even though I don't have you to
precision at this point I know at some
point it's got a whip back downward like
that to meet the other section that I'm
you had to approach this asymptote okay
I've pointed this out before of that
exact position where it turns around and
this exact position over here where this
turns arrest later on we learn about
calculus and dissociation
we'll have tools for finding those spots
but right now I just want to get the
general shape that's all this is a
valium